hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to three scary
[Music]
[Applause]
this is the micro horror arcade trilogy
trilogy for three scary games yes it is
serendipitous at best but I'm going to
get into this trilogy and I'm gonna dig
my teeth into the center of it what is
what is any of these jiggly bastards
okay how to play instructions avoid
Farmar dangle and farmer dongle there
are clues hidden all around the map so
be sure to interact with everything in
order to find out what to do
Pharma dongle can see pretty far but
moves slowly while farmer Daniel is
nearsighted it moves a lot quicker the
first time the farmers catch you they'll
just lock you up the second time they
catch you it's game over
also there's a pig who roams around the
map if he catches you with a key he'll
steal it and you'll have to catch him to
get it back alright so yeah it seems
pretty straightforward oh this is quite
a head Bob but also I can't really see
what whoa andrew is that what that says
on the booth I went into the light why
did I go into the light oh oh
graveyard well that's not a it's not a
farm that is it's not really a farm it's
graveyard very different things what are
they farming corpses why would I be in
here
I don't know I don't know why I'm here I
don't know why I was summoned to do a
beam of light with my name on it and
then I spun into a graveyard next trip
at least I'm assuming this is corn corn
doesn't usually grow just on the top it
usually grows along the stocks what is
just a big old glob of blood okay I
can't open this with my bare hands well
you're just not trying hard enough I
could pry that bad boy off with one hand
tied behind my back
oh oh it's legs at least I think it's
legs okay I don't know why you're under
the ground anywhere here only a little
bit moderately perturbative a box a big
box what do I need a box for oh well I
don't like that well that's for damn
sure I really don't like that what am i
doing by the way where's with the
undulating aliens oh I got a bad feeling
about all this can't open this with my
bare hands again I don't know what that
is is that a trapdoor to under the
ground to beneath the farm is it going
in to the farms upside down what is the
point
Oh have a flashlight I didn't even know
I had a flashlight
all right not that it's incredibly
helpful right
but jeezum similarly my truly what the
hell is an oh oh oh oh okay okay okay
okay okay okay okay okay okay oh wait
wait
oh you can go right through well that's
hardly fair well I don't think that's
playing very fair sir are you dang God
you need to cut that [ __ ] out that's
just a jump-scare
Oh
oh shoot hey no our dangle I don't know
which one you are
oh boy I'm in the blood area oh I am in
the blood area I was just saying that to
be stupid but apparently I is
why why why why would we be doing that
seven yeah that explains everything
thank you the logic is irrefutable okay
drain a meal mummy I swear I've liked
wash my hair fifteen times to get the
Vaseline out and it will not come does
that a big monster snip stepping away or
was it like Dingle and dangle gettin
freaky over there seven I need something
to cut this chain with well that would
be very helpful if I actually add
anything to do that oh let's look behind
me but whoa God
why what the hell how'd you get in here
oh I got bolt cutters what the hell was
that I have no idea what's happening
here
I have no idea what's going on what the
farmers are coming to investigate well
that's unfortunate
tickle dangle wait she was a little bit
difficult when Dingle and dangled we're
both outside of the doors I didn't know
what I could do in regards to that so I
think it was a little unfortunate for me
so you suck
alright let's try it again well gosh I
just don't know where to go I don't know
the full scope of this forest here so I
have no idea how far I am in relation to
the end
you [ __ ] oh oh right that makes
perfect sense
what looks like it can be cut down great
so I can go into the ether over there
also or what are they farming and like I
know that it says they're farmers but
are they really farming that a UFO it's
a new folk like the crops already
harvested get your big combine and just
start getting them on high high high no
need
oh no need oh I'm an idiot I'm an idiot
I'm an idiot ok listen buddy listen
buddy listen dingle-dangle
you're gonna keep me oh oh crap
ok maybe I can swing around yeah yeah
yeah I've got you now I've got you now
okay I don't exactly know where I'm
headed but I am getting away from dongle
dangled crap crap crap crap am i just
heading in a circle oh my god oh my god
oh wow okay breaker is missing a switch
I'm Emile mu oh hi wait that's the same
thing from big face
oh this yeah yeah that's the same thing
for a big face oh so this is the same
developer that made big face and
absolutely no I'm back at the goddamn hi
what are you what am i what am I looking
at hey dude how you doing what do you
got there okay cool good story glad we
can talk hello hi dango dango farm
day-old dango Ferb
tango dog a farm there you'll dongle fur
all right good
great that is just delightful so glad we
could have that conversation what do we
got over here
hey oh wow
need a key in order open that so that's
good
see the thing is I don't know if there's
anything in the farm can happen oh I
found the crew burr I can probably prat
some things open that with which I could
not pry open with my hands and if I
could pry them open then I would be able
to utilize whatever they is I hope I
made myself perfectly clear
I trained in the most elitist love
squats oh there's nothing oh it's a box
of course it's a box why would I think
that it would be a mystical trapdoor
that would lead to an underground
complex of course of course it's a box
ah good crane so all I got to do now is
just find my way back to the other boxes
which one is over there and I can't good
[Music]
how do I get to you this is how I get to
you maybe not maybe not quite how do I
get to you come to me come to me how are
you is where are okay here we go box
I got a Fu's good for me oh so I saw a
fuse in that other area I just didn't
pick it up hey yeah I do need more than
one fuse goddammit okay well I shall not
let that dissuade me no Dingle no dang
gimme damn it
worst Christmas ever be the good I got a
truck key okay not exactly what I was
thinking that I didn't know that there
was gonna be more than one key crap I
have no idea where they are
damn it Jeremy Tommy these boxes are
empty probably only three and I found
him all of them yeah it's a big oh wait
you're gonna steal my key no no no no no
no no my key I earned the key I earned
the key I earned the cake I earned the
key you shut up you shut up don't you
point at me don't you dare
oink at me listen little man ah but I
was just at but I just found it but I
had just found another king I know where
that was god damn it
all right fine it was that goddamn pig
you you're gonna get a face full [ __ ]
get over here oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
Oh pig man where are you going pig boy
you could back you get your ass oh
you're quick why are you so quick oh my
god you get your pig butt back here I am
going to slam my crowbar so far give
give give give give give how do I get
how do I get give me your Testament yeah
oh [ __ ] oh I'm double doomed
I am triple dicks I am quadruple boned
oh god I went right back to the
beginning I could have just gotten the
other key that I found oh this is very
annoying pink pork you lence give how do
I get from you how do I get from you oh
[ __ ] I'm boned no there's no way there
is no way there is no way there is no
way there is no way wait it is
impossible to get the sack back once the
pig has your sack the sack will remain
for all eternity you're just keeping me
on my toes my little toe zero Z's you're
keeping me on them and I know not
appreciate it
was it here was this where that key was
it is okay barn key I'm gonna try to get
out now
and get to the barn which I generally
remember as being somewhere over here
but I might also be very wrong about
that so I don't exactly know where I'm
supposed to go there's got to be like
the barn right I need a key no well you
know I did just kind of okay what's the
barn then what's the barn hey there's
another fuse okay that wait that's
bizarre
wait wait oh there's two different sides
oh I did not know that then this is the
Red Barn Oh interesting
this is where I was trapped they're
coming to investigate but honestly screw
those [ __ ] Oh fascinating
Oh the last fuse Oh interesting
oh this is very interesting Oh
fascinating
okay but there's not the bolt cutters oh
there oh you didn't see nothing and it's
good that you didn't know I pooped down
oh you're coming for me oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
oh [ __ ] what are you what are you what
are you I don't know there was only one
koopa belies a ballute a nas orb into my
being suck it up inside of me okay so I
guess I've got three fuses so that's
something and then I've got bolt cutters
so that's something else maybe I'm
actually closer to the end of this game
than I thought I mean this game has been
going on a lot longer than I thought it
would but hey you know I beggars can't
be choosers oh I got the Freak why did
it work that time why didn't that time
it well whatever you know I'm not gonna
complain because I have two keys
I've got bolt cutters I got uses all I
got to do is get back to the other side
of where I started this monstrosity from
and then hopefully not get caught and
get out maybe maybe
truck would be a faster getaway well you
know I do have the truck key what is
this yup yup the breaker is missing I
gotta get it alright what is it oh this
is different okay for great for that's
very helpful would have garage tool shed
barn would have been really good to know
that I needed to look up the numbers for
that am I ready for what Freddy some
other kind of Freddy I got a shovel oh
my god don't tell me I need to take this
shovel to the Graveyard too then okay
for this is the I believe this is the
tool shed so then that means the green
must be the garage yep
[Music]
okay eight all right good to know eight
so eight [ __ ] their days are common okay
they didn't see me so I could probably
guess the last number I don't know so
eight four oh it doesn't have power oh
oh oh oh so it doesn't okay well that
was a shock okay okay you know actually
this might not be so bad because I have
a shovel so I'm guessing I gotta go to
the graveyard this just so happens to
put me near the graveyard and a five so
this is it I got I got all the goodies I
need a four and five give me this [ __ ]
dig it up dig it dig it up
dig dig it all up oh that's a keep ok
exit key that's good all right listen
I'm just gonna preface this right now
cuz I digging around here if I get to
the end of all this and I get close to
the exit and then I get [ __ ] over at
the last second I will not go through it
all again I will not do it I will not I
will not dot that you can't make me
it won't happen I won't did I shan't do
it I won't do it it won't happen
don't even try I won't do it okay all
right now that work clear are all good
okay
so what I what I just need to make sure
is that these switch isn't like
something over here I don't even know
what the switch would look like I mean
maybe I have everything I need
maybe considering I have a truck key and
the exit key maybe oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh
okay see if I can sneak in there there's
no side entrance is there I can get I
can get by okay so I just got to get
through here I mean it's probably that
there's another box in here that I have
not over no no it's probably just that
there's another box somewhere oh my god
please pig don't take my keys Pig do not
take my keys Pig please I'm begging you
Pig don't do it okay good good good
we're all good man you think that I
would know the route through here by now
I'm still trying to piece it together in
my head but it is a bit convoluted still
[Music]
[ __ ]
goddammit
let's just see what happens if I use the
exit key and then you know what about
the truck
okay truck truck get in the truck and go
for it truck would be a faster getaway
well you know how about you do it how
about you do it how about you get in
there all right fine I'm gonna go for it
I'm running I'm just gonna run I'm gonna
run oh [ __ ] me
wow he did the exact thing it did the
exact thing that I said it was gonna do
and no I'm not gonna try that again
I'm not gonna try that again at all no
I'm not gonna do it I'm not gonna do it
you can't make me you can't make me the
game was fine it was fine the game fine
I'm not gonna do it again just because I
seem to be enraged doesn't mean that it
was a bad game moving on to the next
game in this trilogy all right
similarly this one is called lanky long
ki avoid lanky long key while finding
all five artifacts that are necessary to
banish him you must find them in the
same order that they're listed on your
checklist once you've found every
artifact you must find a way out of the
storage floor of your office building do
not let lanky long kisi you do not
attempt to collect any artifacts out of
mortar linking long key is the only
danger here believe it or not so explore
everywhere you may even find some
familiar faces okay so how am I supposed
to know the order again you probably
said but I don't remember to go to the
storage space before office building
supplies are 30 yards you know to fill
this Hill he'll give you bullets you
could take the elevator straight down
all right now for the basement
oh nothing suspicious just just get the
stuff dad come on in for work oh you're
doing a great job by the way thank you
thank you I'll see you soon okay
thank you that was very
oh is that lanky one is it that might be
like lucky don't collect any artists
[Music]
what Oh what
I love all the sound effects done by
mouth what what uh heck all right okay
good
that is hmm bizarre hi Oh
[Music]
okay
lanky long key length long link oh is
that a these boobs or these something
else oh okay blankie blankie long key I
like this one I like this one it's got
some charm
you know though it's got the hot spot
also where was this list you said
something about a list of the order that
I'm supposed to get these in and I would
like that list I am uncertain of the
order you are execute that big face oh
it's big face big face has been
neutralized
big face it is dead I don't know where
lanky long he went who he feels that
linking like he is over here no thank
you happened what the hell you're not
you will not link you know link you know
oh [ __ ] that's a blankie lucky
oh okay lankey lucky you Oh blankie
wonky blankie long he seems to be a bit
all right let's find it again I don't
know why it turned into the pit of hell
going in this way Oh blankie long key
you so funny always to me of the funny
tapes oh oh there it is right click
souls of the unborn well I sure wish I
knew what the hell that even meant what
does that mean
okay I don't know I don't know how am I
supposed to know what this is I don't
know how do I know how am I supposed to
know how do I know
no I lankey I long key LAN clonk
lanky long key that syndrome thank you
okay okay okay I got one
I know some people might agree to that
nine out of ten doctors agree that's
how do I get away from you I don't know
how to do that oh that is a hallway okay
that was souls of the unborn how do I
stop him okay good
how do I stop him from finding me I
found it it's impossible
turns out it's impossible turns out I'll
give it one more try that's all given
all right okay so I heard him burning
flesh see how do you know what is why
okay away
[Music]
so I'm assuming that calls to him
slang stir who pissed me who dares
pissed me thats the same creature [ __ ] -
[ __ ] well you know you win some you lose
on my gas oh hi that's bizarre
that was the door
okay so I've got one and the other
things don't really have names on them
so I guess I'm just gonna kind of guess
I've read I don't agency oh well see how
that is handli unfair you dick hole
dickweed oh yeah lanky luck
alright game's impossible as I've
discovered and have proven before a game
is impossible but that's linkie linkie
not bad a challenge to be sure and I'm
sure there's plenty of interesting
events that happen but they're
impossible I'm afraid
no human could possibly beat that and if
any human would like to try and leave a
link to the game in the description
below but now there's one more game here
which I think might be the most profound
game of them all clearly the developer
put the most time into this title of any
other game that they had this one is
called escape the poopoo
oh no it is legitimately escaped the
booboo house Wow okay I think at a
nightmare like this once avoid the boo
boo man and find the correct escape pipe
to win passing behind toilet like this
[ __ ] three men spawn a Dookie or do
nothing at all one Dookie could also be
found hidden in each room the green
Dookie doors required Dookie you can
only hold one Dookie at a time pull the
levers scattered around the map to flush
all the poo men away good luck this game
is very difficult
oh yeah like the others weren't okay
great oh wow great hey a Dookie is that
a Dookie whoa oh boy oh boy oh I'm stuck
no no they got me oh boy oh boy oh boy
oh boy oh boy is that a Dookie oh boy oh
boy oh boy oh boy that's a Dookie I
can't have the Duke yeah I just get to
look at the Dookie
where is the lever you said there was
gonna be a lever can I have it can I
have it
you'd only carry one Sookie apparently
good to know
oh you're green I don't like that can I
have it
oh my gudd oh my gudd that's unfair why
am I playing this why am I taking this
any sort of seriously why five I've done
this to myself why would I do this to
myself I am playing a poop game it is a
poop game I can definitely not carry
more than one
oh wow a lot of do men a lot of doodoo
head in doodoo man I see how this is it
or no keys for me anymore keys don't
exist
he's Kanak the skeezer and unreality
there we go
I'm not seeing much in the way of levers
I thought I heard something about there
being levers in this game hey a pipe
ah you gave me false hope stop stop stop
so the green ones they come after you
directly they attack my health correctly
the brown ones just wander aimlessly I
get it I see Oh
oh I made so much progress honestly I
don't think this one's as hard as the
other ones I think it's just like you
gotta find it so it's random luck
where's the goddamn flush wha
really really really you're gonna spawn
by out of my drift
[Music]
alright clean toilet clean Shirley wait
wait which way did I just get turned
around - I've got damn ID oh well that
said while are you [ __ ] [ __ ]
[Music]
okay I'm done all right well I actually
tried I actually tried and then a green
one's gonna spawn in the corner where I
can't move it's fine okay all right that
what a poopy game a very poopy but
difficult to play yes yeah very you're
right about that one bird tough all
right so this was the micro horror
arcade trilogy trilogy to be perfectly
honest like even though I was frustrated
at many times and I was giving his [ __ ]
and it gave me [ __ ] and we gave each
other [ __ ] still not bad games and the
whole trilogy cost a buck 50 so a buck
50 for all that not a bad deal you know
still have added still imaginative had
some jump scares in there maybe not the
most elegantly crafted games but hey
they worked or can you ask for its game
so anyway thank you everybody so much
for watching if you want to play any of
these a link to the entire trilogy
in the description below and as always I
will see you
[Music]